[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDEEP DINESH: My
name is Sandeep.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google Cloud.
And today we're going to
talk about world scale
microser-- that woke
you all up, didn't it?
So yeah, let's just
jump right into it.
This is a somewhat
advanced Kubernetes talk.
So if you're here, I expect
you to know what Docker is.
Yeah?
OK, what containers and
orchestrators and things
like that.
OK, we're good.
You're in the right room.
So we're going to
architect an app from start
to finish that has to
work around the world,
store state, be fast,
and a new term I just
invented called LowOps,
because it's not NoOps, right?
And we only have an
hour to talk about it.
So what are we going to do?
Memes.
Means are the best.
These are legal approved memes.
Of course, I'm just
going to give a caveat.
Everything you see
here could have
been built in static JavaScript
page, and launched in a CDN,
and been globally distributed.
But you know what.
I wanted a good
microservices example.
And Hello World
just doesn't cut it.
We need to build something
somewhat real, but not too
complicated.
And so a little meme generator
seemed right up the alley.
And so here's that agenda.
We're going to talk about
what we're building.
And then we're going to
go with the stateless part
and the stateful, multi-cluster,
and then configuration.
And then my favorite
category, other stuff.
Overview.
So how are we going to do this?
We're going to do something
that looks like this.
We're going to have six
different microservices.
There's five on the screen,
but there's a secret sixth one.
And when the user comes
to our landing page,
they're going to come
in to the web server.
And the web server will
just hit the Redis cache.
It'll get a list of
10 images and show it.
The HTML will be
served and the images
will be pulled from
GCS regional buckets.
Makes perfect sense.
When you want to make a new
meme, it gets a little bit more
complicated.
Again, the request comes
into our web server.
And now it talks to the
meme creator microservice.
And all this does is
generate a JPEG and stream
it back to the web server.
Now at this point,
it's just going
to stream that JPEG straight
back to the user, right?
Very, very fast.
We're not waiting for it
to be stored anywhere.
We're not waiting for
replication, nothing.
At the same time,
we're going to send it
to the image store service.
Now, the image store
service is the one
that's going to send it
to the regional bucket,
store the image there,
and get the link back.
Now, it's going to take
that and the metadata that
was used to generate the image
and put that into the cache
and into the MongoDB database.
Now unfortunately,
unlike Cloud Spanner,
MongoDB does not
become consistent
around the world magically.
In fact it's very inconsistent.
So we're going to run it
in one cluster instead
of all the clusters.
So these are all local
clusters that we're running.
And the MongoDB database is
in one of the clusters only.
So we have to have some sort of
cross-cluster service discovery
as well.
And then search.
For search, it's a
little bit simple again.
The web request comes in.
We talk to the
image store service
with the requested terms.
It talks to MongoDB
for the links.
It gets those links
and it serves it
from the appropriate
regional buckets.
So the interesting thing
here is that search
is around the world, right?
If you generate a
meme in Japan and it's
stored in our Tokyo
bucket, you can still
find it in the United States.
But the Redis cache is
local to the local cluster.
So this is a pretty
reasonable architecture.
Nothing too complicated.
But it's using six
different microservices,
which I find really fun.
And of course, to
do this, we're going
to use the power of Kubernetes.
And we're going to use the power
of Google Container Engine.
Oh, yeah.
It's the only way I'm going
to ever wear this shirt.
Like who invented this thing?
It's like half the shirt
is the logo, right?
So here we go.
I get to wear it at Cloud Next.
So let's start easy-- stateless.
I expect most people
in the audience
to know exactly what
I'm going to do here.
So the meme creator
service is a great example
of a stateless app.
All it does is take in
a few simple parameters
and return a JPEG.
It's 100% stateless
and configless.
There's one API, a get
with URL parameters.
No dependencies.
It's a single, standalone
Docker container.
So here's the things we need
to run this stateless service.
The first is the
concept of a pod.
Again, this is more
101, but we had
to learn this to
go further, right?
So you have a group or one
or more containers that share
a local host and are
always scheduled together.
They all share the same IP.
They live and die together.
Then we have deployments.
And basically, this says,
I want so many pods to run,
what the pods need,
and the deployment
takes care of the rest
using the replica set.
And we have a service.
And because we can have
arbitrary number of pods,
we need a stable endpoint to
do service discovery and load
balancing.
So if you look at the meme
creator service and deployment,
it looks something like this.
You have a bunch of
pods with a random ID.
And let's say I
want three of them.
When I have a request come
into the meme creator service,
it'll round robin load
balance to an available pod.
That's it.
If a pod dies, it'll be replaced
by a new one with a new ID.
We don't regenerate pods.
And so that's really basic.
This is the Hello
World of Kubernetes.
Let's just go
through a quick demo.
And I'll also record my
screen, just in case.
So here we have--
I'm going to run a
deployment with two
replicas with the NGINX
image and open up port 80.
So our deployment is created.
Very easy.
What does that look like?
Something like this.
Now, this is the full YAML.
Of course, in real life,
you would find a lot less.
I can see that I have
two available replicas.
I have two replicas in my spec.
Port 80's open.
Image is NGINX.
Exactly what we specified
in that command.
Now what I'm going
to do is expose
that using a load balancer.
So I'm going to go kubectl
expose and the nginx-deployment
and type load balancer.
This, of course, as
most of you know,
will spin up a Google
Cloud TCP load balancer.
And TCP load balancers
are not global.
They're very regional.
And you can see that
the nginx-deployment
has been created.
But the external IP
is still pending.
So in a few seconds, we'll
get that external IP.
That's good.
The fun waiting game.
We're going to be
doing this a lot.
It's not even exciting.
I'm just going to keep going.
Can we switch back
to the slides?
I'll show you it later.
All right, cool.
So then IP would have
come and we would have
seen Hello World from NGINX.
Very exciting.
Not really.
So let's go to something
a little bit more
exciting and a little
bit more complicated.
So stateful, right?
Containers can have state.
And the best example of
this is MongoDB database.
We're not running this in GCE.
We're not running
this somewhere else.
We're running it in Kubernetes.
But there's problems.
There are serious
problems with this,
especially if you try to do it
with a deployment and replica
sets.
Among MongoDB replica set, not
to be confused with Kubernetes
replica sets, are
complicated to set up
and are complicated
to keep running.
Every single instruction
on MongoDB's website
requires you to
log into a machine,
connect to the mongod client,
do some commands here and there,
set up your rs.conf, do
all this complicated stuff.
Turns out in Kubernetes land,
SSHing is not something you do,
right?
It requires high
availability and performance.
A database can't go down.
It's very hard for it to
recover, things like that.
And it has to have
high performance
SSDs, things like that.
Of course, obviously, needs
to store persistent data,
otherwise, it's not
called a database.
But MongoDB is not cloud native.
A lot of databases can kind of
deal with node failure, deal
with new member addition,
deal with all those kind
of non-cloud stuff.
I mean, cloud stuff very easily.
MongoDB, sadly cannot.
It really depends on hosts.
And it can't be load
balanced, at least not easily.
You should really connect to
all members of the replica set.
You can't connect to a
load balancer service
and have the requests
pushed through like a proxy.
You can, but it's
not native, again.
So what we're going to do is use
a few things that were released
in the latest version
of Kubernetes,
especially something
called stateful sets.
So the first thing we're
going to talk about
are persistent volumes.
These are data volumes
that persist even
if the pod restarts or moves.
Then we have sidecar
containers, that it's basically
a container that helps the
primary container do its job.
So we'll take a look at why
we need that with MongoDB.
Then we have stateful
sets, which are basically
a set of pods that can
scale horizontally,
just like replica sets.
But each pod maintains a
consistent network and disk
identity.
So this means that
if you lose pod two,
you'll get pod two back.
And it'll attach the same
disk that it had previously,
which is very important
for databases.
And finally, the last
piece of the puzzle
is a headless service,
which is a service that
does no load
balancing, but instead,
exposes the pods directly
with their own DNS names.
So what we have here
is our headless service
and our MongoDB stateful set.
The first thing that happens
is if a volume does not
exist for that pod, it'll
provision a volume for you.
Then it'll spin up the pod
and the mongod instance
will store its data
in that volume.
And then we say, I
want three of these,
so it does three
of these for us.
Now, what happens is the
configuration sidecar
is a little Node.js process
that actually has a Kubernetes
API built into it.
So ill talk to the
headless service
to discover the other members
of the MongoDB replica set.
Now, this is really cool.
This means we don't have to
actually configure MongoDB
manually.
Instead, we just had the sidecar
autoconfigure our cluster
for us.
So once it talks and figures
out the rest of the members,
it'll create the replica
set for us automatically.
And when our app wants to talk
to the MongoDB replica set,
it bypasses the headless service
and talks directly to the pods.
So the first pod is called
mongo-0.mongo, mongo-1.mongo,
and mongo-2.mongo.
We're not talking to
the Mongo service,
we're talking to each
pod directly using
the headless service.
All right, can you switch back?
So at this point,
we have our IP.
We can obviously go there, but
you can take my word for it,
it works.
Here you go.
That's an error.
That's great.
I don't even know.
All right, did I
do something wrong?
Who knows.
It's not interesting.
Let's just keep going.
So I'm going to
watch, make stateful1.
And I was too lazy to
even copy the YAML,
so I was doing it
from GitHub directly.
So the first thing I'm
doing is creating this thing
called a storage class.
And a storage class is
not technically necessary,
but I like it because I can
control what kind of disk
gets provisioned.
And I really want an SSD.
So I made a new source
class called fast
that provision Kubernetes.
It makes Kubernetes aware
of the GCE persistent disk
and makes you able to provision
SSDs on the fly, which is nice.
And now I'm actually going to
create the MongoDB service.
And here's what happens.
You can see that we have
our mongo-0 spinning up.
But we don't have the
other two replicas.
This is because the stateful
set actually spins up
the pods one at a time.
And if you think
about it, this is
really important for most
traditional databases,
because the replica set
has to be created first
before a member can join.
And so what this
ensures is that you
don't have two people thinking
that they're both the primary,
and then you have to do
reelections and things
like that.
Instead, we wait till
the first container
is created before
starting the next one,
and before starting
the next one.
Obviously, the first step
is to actually create
those persistent disks.
So you can see that we have
three persistent disks being
created already.
And they're bound to our nodes.
So we have storage
mongo-0, storage mongo-1,
and storage mongo-2.
Now, the other thing to notice
is the Mongo service itself.
So we have our nginx-deployment
on the very bottom
that has a cluster IP
and an external IP.
The Mongo service has
a none for cluster IP.
Now, you might think that's
kind of weird, and it is.
It's because it's
a headless service.
There is no load balancer
for the Mongo service.
We don't need it.
Instead, it exposes the
pods, mongo-0, mongo-1,
and mongo-2 directly
to our application.
Now, let's just go
back to the slides.
We'll let that create
in the background.
Nope, doesn't work.
Oh, it's the wrong I.
A wrong copy-paste.
See, that's why.
There we go.
See, it works.
No one can see it.
Can we switch back?
I want to show people
that I actually did this.
I'm just talking to myself here.
There, see!
Ha, ha, ha, I win.
All right, let's go back.
All right, so if you
want to learn more
about how to do that a
little bit more deep,
I have a blog post on
the Kubernetes blog.
You can go to that short
link to learn more, or just
search for that.
I mean, there's a good search
engine out there I heard.
And it will give you that.
I go into pretty much exactly
what I did, but in detail.
I explain what the YAMLs do.
I explain what the sidecar does,
all that kind of good stuff.
OK, so now let's talk
about, in my opinion,
the most interesting thing.
Why is it, in my opinion,
the most interesting thing?
Because it's the latest
thing I've done, right?
So new is always interesting.
Here's the deal.
I have friends in Azure.
I have friends in AWS.
Public clouds, all of them, have
data centers around the world.
Look at how many there are.
They're just like
dot dot dot dot dot.
Like you can't even
count them, right?
And we just launched
three more today, right?
California, Canada, and
the last one, but I forgot.
That's OK.
They're all very
important, don't worry.
But the thing is,
there's so many of them.
Do you know how
many people do this?
So many people do this.
They just say, we're going to
go to production in one zone,
with one provider.
And I'm telling
you I have-- again,
I know people do this on GCP.
I have friends at AWS.
They say the same
thing happens there.
It's like, why, why?
Because it's hard, right.
Yeah, multi-region is hard.
Multi-cloud is hard.
But it's 2017 and we
can do better than this.
And Kubernetes is really
trying to make it easier,
but it's still hard.
It's still hard.
Don't get me wrong.
But we have to do this.
Otherwise, when a cloud provider
goes down for any reason,
and we all do, things
just break, right?
I saw a great blog post
saying, because of Kubernetes,
with the S3 outage,
they failed over just
seamlessly without
any sort of downtime,
because they had
this redundancy.
And this happens
to everyone, right?
It's not just AWS or Google.
Everyone has downtime.
So with Kubernetes, you can
really hedge against that.
So we're going to
talk about two things.
The first thing is the
federation control plan.
And it's basically
a service that
manages the global state of
all the federated clusters.
And when anyone
says control plane,
all it means is global
state management, right?
It's like a global variable
that's managed somewhere.
It's a fancy word for that.
And the really nice thing
that came out recently
is the kubefed tool.
How many of you have heard
of this or used it before?
A few people.
Cool.
So if you've ever set up
federated clusters before,
it was a pain.
You had to deploy all these
YAMLs and config maps and all
this stuff.
With the kubefed tool,
it's a few lines,
and you're like kubefed,
and you're just done.
So almost.
That's why I'm here
talking about it, right?
So we're going to
take a look at that.
Can you switch to the demo?
So what I'm going to do is
I have a huge makefile that
looks something like this.
It's beautiful.
And we're going to talk about
some things we have to do
before we can get started.
So the first thing is
federated clusters require DNS.
And this is because if you want
to do cross-cluster service
discovery, you have to--
and especially cross-cloud
service discovery--
say that 10 times fast--
you have to have a DNS
system that can route traffic
over the public internet.
Even if you're using private
DNS, you still need DNS.
And so-- oh, hello.
OK.
Weird.
Can I just unplug this
and plug it back in,
or what should I do right now?
I'm confused.
I can keep talking.
So anyway, you need
DNS, things like that.
I'm going to unplug
this real fast.
So what we're going
to do is actually
use Google Cloud DNS to
configure our clusters.
And I'll plug it back in now.
Yeah, there we go.
So-- kind of.
Oh, man.
[LAUGHTER]
Everyone gather around,
we'll just look at my laptop.
Oh, there we go.
Cool.
So right now I
have, basically, I
bought a domain name called
WorldClassMicroservices.com,
because it's very long and no
one likes long domain names,
so they're cheap.
And right now it has nothing.
It just has a few name
servers and that's it.
But what I'm going to do is
I've created that managed
zone and I've given it a name.
So now Kubernetes can
actually connect to that.
Now, what we're going to do is
actually use the kubefed tool
to deploy federation.
Here we go.
So that's the line
we're going to run,
kubefed init, and
this is the name
of our federated context, which
is worldscalemicroservices.
And we're going to
give it a host cluster.
Now, this is really interesting.
We're actually
hosting the controller
for the multi-federated
clusters inside of a cluster.
So it's self-hosted.
So you're not
wasting any resources
with another host
controller kind of thing.
It's actually hosting it
inside one of its own clusters,
which is really cool.
And the last thing
is we're going
to pass it that DNS zone name,
infra.worldscalemicroservices
dot com dot.
It's very important to
put that last dot there.
If you don't, it's
not going to work.
I learned that the hard way.
So the next thing
that we're going to do
is actually-- oh my gosh.
All right, we're going
to join all the clusters
into our federated service.
And what we're going to do
is just loop through all
the clusters that we have.
And here's the
clusters that we have.
I've made one in
all our public data
centers that you can
launch something in today.
So Asia East, Asia Northeast,
West, Central, East, and East--
West-- whatever.
Why do I have two Wests?
I have no idea.
OK.
And non-federated is what I
was running the other demos in.
I don't understand what's
going on, but that's OK.
So right now we've had
our control plane deployed
and it's running our API
server at that IP address.
So now what I'm
going to do is just
loop through all the
different clusters
and run the kubefed
join command.
And this will just dump a
bunch of crap on the screen,
but that's OK.
I'll look at the first one.
So it says kubefed context
worldscalemicroservices.
So that's our federated context.
Join cluster, and the
cluster, the new cluster,
is going to be cluster
asia-northeast1.
Then I'm going to give it the
cluster context and the host
cluster context.
And that's basically
all you have to do
and it's automatically
joined into the cluster.
So now if I go kubectl--
let me do this.
So you can see that
we have all six
of our clusters up
and ready, right?
And you just had to have
run with the context
of worldscalemicroservices,
which is
our virtual federated context.
Cool.
OK, so now there's
one more step,
which is very critical
to get this working.
And that is actually
updating the DNS controllers
in all of our clusters.
So right now, all the clusters
just understand themselves.
They don't understand
the outside world.
It's a big scary place.
What we want to do is make
it so that they connect
to the new DNS managed
zone that we created,
that infra.worldscale
microservices.com domain zone,
and use it.
So to do that before,
we had to have
a bunch of complicated stuff,
patch the Kubernetes DNS,
all this crazy stuff.
Now all we have to do
is deploy a config map,
which I'll talk
about more later.
So I'm going to create a
config map that basically says,
the federated domain is that--
infra.worldscale
microservices.com.
And now I'm going to
sleep for 20 seconds
and do something really weird.
I'm going to kill
all the DNS pods.
Why?
Because DNS is sticky
and I want to make sure
that they all die and re-get
the new DNS configuration.
I'm not 100% sure if this is
needed, but it works well.
So you know, if it
works, do it, right?
So I'm just going to go
through every single cluster
and delete kube-dns.
And because it's running under
a replication controller,
it just spins up
another one, right?
Easy.
I don't have to care.
So now we're done.
We have set up six federated
clusters around the world.
We just set up six federated
clusters around the world,
there we go.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, can we switch
back to the demo--
to the slides?
So you might be
wondering why didn't I
just make a really
big cluster that
just spanned the whole world?
Why did I go with
the second one that
looks a lot more complicated
and looks like Christmas?
It's because reasons.
And the reasons are, what
if that VM on the left
is in Australia and the
other VM is in Singapore?
Well, they probably
shouldn't talk to each other
if there's a closer one, right?
And what happens
if this just dies?
What if the cluster dies?
All services around the
world just die, right?
With the second option, even
if the global control plane
goes down, all
the local clusters
are still up and running,
functional, fully functional,
right?
You just can't address
them at the global scale.
And if little clusters
go down, it's OK.
Traffic will reroute
intelligently
to available clusters.
How?
Something like this.
So if service A, the app
wants to connect to service A,
obviously it'll just connect
to the one in the cluster.
But if it wants to
connect to service C,
it will say, hey,
there's nothing
available in the cluster.
Let me go to another cluster.
That's pretty cool.
This means that you don't have
to have your services running
in every cluster if it's
not a highly used service.
In fact, we'll talk
about something like that
in this part right now.
Because if you go to
mywebsite.com, from there,
you probably want to go to
Sao Paulo data center, not
somewhere else, right?
In fact, your users
around the world
probably wanted to go to the
data center closest to them.
But they all want to just
type in mywebsite.com.
It's super annoying when I
have to type in mywebsite.uk,
or my website dot
whatever, right?
I just want to type
in mywebsite.com
and get the fastest result.
Turns out we have this.
This is an actual map--
actual map.
Those black points are
actually our points
of presences around
the world, which means
that if you connect
to one of these,
you're routed automatically
using SDN networking, right?
So we have an anycast system
to the closest data center.
What this means is every single
one of these points of presence
broadcasts the same IP address.
And the user connects to the
closest one automatically.
This means you're not worrying
about DNS configuration
or anything like that.
You just say, I have one IP.
Google, you take
care of the rest.
And so how do you do that?
Again, federated ingress.
This is a native Kubernetes
L7 load balancer and router.
And it's federated, which means
that you get one IP address
for all of your clusters.
And the way you do this on
Google Cloud, of course,
is the HTTPS load balancer.
Now, this is our global
L7 load balancing solution
with a single IP
address, SSL offload,
and in alpha, IP v-6 support,
which is really, really good.
So let's take a look
at how that works.
So what I'm going to do is just
deploy all my microservices
right now.
So I'm going to say,
deploy-deployment,
deploy-service.
The first thing I
want to do is Redis.
All right.
There we go.
Boom.
Then I'm going to
the meme creator.
Sweet.
Then I'm going to do--
what else do I have?
I don't even know.
Let's see, I'm going
to do the website.
So this is our web front
end, and we're good to go.
Now, I'm also going to
deploy our MongoDB stack.
And because it's
only in one cluster,
it's a little bit different.
And I'm going to deploy
this little thing called
database helper, which I
will talk about in a second.
Now, if I do a make
get service, I'm
just going to loop
through all the clusters
and get all the services.
So you can see that with
just those commands,
it basically federated
all of these tasks
into all six clusters, right?
I ran it on the
worldscalemicroservices
context.
And because that's a
virtual federated context,
it automatically distributed all
the pods into all the clusters.
I didn't have to log
into each one and deploy.
So of course, what we want
to do now is the ingress.
So let's do that.
OK.
So can we go back to the
slides for one second?
Perfect, thank you.
This is all I need
to do for ingress.
And this creates that
global load balancer.
You can see that looks really
simple, except for one line.
That weird line that says
kubernetes.io/ingress.global
static ip name
kubernetes-ingress.
So this is because we
need to actually give it
that one static IP address.
Otherwise, it'll all
try to bring its own.
And this was really
simple to do.
Can we switch back to my laptop?
All I had to do was this.
Where is it?
Let's see, ingress,
which is somewhere here.
gcloud compute addresses create
kubernetes english --global.
This will create a global IP
address for me on Google Cloud.
Once I do that, I can use
this Kubernetes ingress
in my Kubernetes natively.
I don't have to actually go
ahead and click any buttons
on the UI or anything like that.
So now, if we go back
to our networking page,
right here, this
networking page,
you can see that I
have these TCP load
balancers being created.
And those are for
the database helper,
which I'll get to in a second.
But we also have this sweet
HTTPS load balancer created.
And so you can see that we have
all our backends automatically
added to it.
Of course, it's not healthy yet.
It's still spinning up.
And each one of them has
just this one IP address.
So if I run make.ingress, you
can see that all of my clusters
all have the same IP address for
the service all over the world.
And it's probably still
spinning up, but let's try it.
It's still spinning up.
That's OK.
Now, we'll wait for that.
And when that's going up, we'll
just go back to the slides
real fast and talk
about configuration.
Because why not
easy coding, right?
Why is there no term
called easy coding?
These are interesting.
The regional buckets.
For a lot of people, they want
their data to be regional.
They don't want it to be
distributed around the world.
Sure, you've got a
little bit less uptime,
but you want it to
be cheaper, maybe.
Mostly for memes.
Who wants to pay for memes?
And you want it to be
regional so it's faster.
But where?
How do you know which
bucket to write to, right?
US Central, Asia
East, Mars-- oh, wait.
That's a leak.
Sorry.
Nope.
Mars isn't-- is a rumor.
We don't have one of those.
You could do
something like this.
You can get the current
zone dynamically,
because GCE will report what
data center it's running in.
And then you have this
huge mapping table saying,
if I'm running in US West
1A, then use bucket 1.
And oh my gosh.
Every time you
add something new,
let's say you want to add
S3 into this, well, OK.
Got to go edit it, right?
And that sucks.
What if you could just do this?
Just use the
environment variable
and automatically get it.
That sounds good to me.
So what we're going to
do is use a config map
to store that information.
So this is basically some
configuration information
that's exposed to a container,
either as an environment
variable or a file.
And then a secret is basically
a config map, but obfuscated.
There's a lot of
debate in the community
over it's not encrypted.
Yes, it's not encrypted.
You can use Vault. Kelsey
has a great tutorial on how
you can use Vault to make
truly encrypted secrets.
But yeah, right now the default
thing is just obfuscate it.
Just to keep in mind.
All right, so let's
go back to the demo.
At this point, I hope it's up.
Let's see.
There we go.
Awesome.
So here is my thing.
So you can see that
it's detecting that it's
running in the US West zone.
Obviously, because
we're in California.
And here I have this
interesting website
that I hope works, because it's
not mine, called GeoScreenshot.
And I'm going to take a
screenshot of this IP address
from Germany,
Singapore, and New York.
Can people-- no one
can see that, right?
Let me try to zoom in.
You can see from Germany, it's
Europe West, which makes sense.
From Singapore, it's Asia
East, which makes sense.
And from New York, it's US East.
So yeah, this is
actually really working.
And if you see this
on YouTube, it's
not going to work, because I'm
going to turn the service off,
so don't even try it.
But it works and
it's really cool.
So obviously here, we're
going to be in the West Coast.
I can't fake my location.
Google is pretty
smart about that.
So we're just going to use
the West Coast buckets.
So what I want to do is do this
thing called set up buckets.
And it's going to fail,
fail, fail, fail, fail.
Why?
Because I already did it,
kind of because nothing
would have actually launched if
I didn't have the config map.
If you don't have a config
map and deployment depends
on that config
map, it'll actually
be pending until that
config map is deployed,
which makes a lot of sense.
What I did is I made
a different config
map for every single
cluster with the same name.
And then all it does--
if we can switch
back to the slides.
I keep picking up the wrong one.
All it does is it
gives the bucket
name for that region, right?
But you can see everything's the
same except that actual value
of the bucket name.
So the first one would go
in a US East data center,
so A-East, that's for
America-East, I guess.
And A-West-- I'm not very
creative with names--
is America-West.
And if we can go back to--
yep, thank you.
If we go to our cloud
storage browser,
you can see I have basically a
bucket for all of my regions.
And I have this test bucket.
So the test bucket is
a multi-regional bucket
that I was using originally.
You can see that the regions
are actually local to that data
center, which is really cool.
Versus the multi-regional
bucket is for that region.
So if we go into
our US West bucket,
you can see that
it's currently empty.
Now, let's make a meme.
My friend Cameron has generously
donated his beautiful dog
and cat.
So we'll say puppers are
the best, and create.
And we get a pupper.
No, we don't get a pupper.
Yay, no pupper.
What's going on?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Why did it not work?
Because I don't have my image
creator ser-- like image store.
So it's just not even
storing any images.
Got to do that.
Deployment, deploy-service,
image store.
There we go.
Sweet.
Now let's do a make-get pods.
Make sure that's up and running.
Here we go.
Got a little crash loop.
Oh, interesting.
So our image store
service is creating.
I have a bad feeling I can't
access Docker help from here.
Huh, interesting.
So basically, our
MongoDB pod is not
creating, which is
really interesting.
It's dependent on Docker help.
Everything else is not.
So I wonder what's going on.
And this is why-- this is
crash loop back offing--
because the database
helper is trying
to connect to our
MongoDB replica
set which is not existing.
That's OK.
So we can see your image
store service is creating.
The nice thing
about microservices
is that they can
fail with some grace.
Let's refresh that.
Here we go.
You can see that
because the image store
service is up and running,
those requests got created.
Man, come on, guys.
Who is that?
The cloud is angry at you.
And if you go to this
website, you can make memes.
Sure, go ahead.
Just do it.
But because MongoDB is down,
the searching will not work.
The interesting thing is all
of these memes, once Mongo
comes back up, will be saved.
And we'll talk more
about that in a second.
But around the
world, these would
be stored in different buckets.
And here, if we refresh
our bucket, here we go.
Bunch of people are make memes.
If anyone puts anything
inappropriate-- oh,
I'm not even going try.
All right.
We're going to
close the website.
There we go.
Not tempted.
All right, so if we can go
back to the slides, please?
Cool.
So this is the other stuff.
Let's go back.
And this is like, I think,
the most important part
of the talk.
Everything else is great.
It's really like, wow,
we did stuff, right?
But this took me, basically, all
of January to make by myself.
All six microservices.
And I learned a lot about
building microservices.
The first thing you
have to think about
is this-- sync versus async.
So synchronous
point-to-point communication
is pretty easy to do.
And I think Kubernetes
really makes
it easy to do more
than just normal.
If you have your app and it
wants to talk to a service,
it just makes a
request to the service.
And that automatically load
balances to an available pod,
and the pod gives it back.
It doesn't go
through the service.
I don't know why I did that.
It goes directly to the pod.
But it's pretty easy, right?
I don't have to worry about how
many pods i have or anything.
I just hit the service
and we're good to go.
This can be done
with the REST API.
It can go with gRPC, or
any other RPC framework.
Either way, like
service discovery
is basically free, right?
And it feels native
to Kubernetes.
Here I would have
three tweets that say,
like, you can't do
microservices with sync.
But legal wouldn't let me
put tweets on my slides,
so it's blank.
But just imagine
the tweets there.
Angry people saying,
you have to have async,
otherwise it's just a
distributed monolith.
And I kind of agree and
kind of disagree with that.
This is what an async
kind of looks like.
Your pod puts something
into a work queue.
The other pods just kind of
read from that work queue,
finish the work,
and maybe put it
into another queue for
the first pod to consume.
And so if you look
at our architecture
for creating a new meme, I feel
that these two pieces really
fit the async nature.
Why?
Because if I say create a meme,
enter, and nothing comes out,
it's broken.
It doesn't matter if it
comes out in like 10 seconds.
Async does not matter.
It has to be synchronous.
I want it
Through the lifetime of the
request, it has to finish.
However, storing the
image in the backend
needs to actually finish.
It can't fail, right?
So that needs to
be asynchronous.
And it doesn't matter about
performance as much real, like,
in the lifetime of the request.
Instead, it matters that
it gets done eventually.
And it gets done consistently.
So what I did is database
helper is actually
listening to a Pub/Sub topic.
And this Pub/Sub topic
is getting requests
from image store.
And once that request comes
in, that database helper
is talking directly to
MongoDB and putting it in.
But the other way around, when
you want to query the database,
that's a synchronous service.
The database helper
exposes a RESTful interface
and I query MongoDB
through that REST proxy.
Do not expose your
MongoDB to the internet.
[LAUGHS] Don't do it.
And use passwords people,
please, please, please.
So Google Cloud Pub/Sub is an
asynchronous message queue.
Many-to-many communication.
Fully managed.
It's NoOps, serverless.
It just scales to millions
of messages instantly.
You don't have to warm it
up or anything like that.
There's a gRPC API
that's really fast,
and a REST API that
you can use as well.
And a bunch of libraries
for about 10 languages.
The normal 10 languages that
we support on Google Cloud.
So before we go to
the next one, this is,
I think, really important
to understand why
you want something like this.
If you've ever had--
this is why I fed--
those memes won't
be stored in MongoDB
now because the
database is down,
but they'll be
buffered in Pub/Sub,
waiting for the database
helper to come back up
and read from them.
And then they'll all come in.
So even though I had
database downtime,
it's still safe
sitting in Pub/Sub.
And of course, I mean,
I work for Google Cloud.
I recommend using one of
our managed databases.
But for a lot of people,
they want to run their own.
So I'm not going to make
any judgments there.
Only a little bit.
So the other thing
I want to talk about
are the Stackdriver tools.
How many of you went to
a Stackdriver talk today?
OK, fair amount.
I like them a lot, mostly
for something like this.
Logging was pretty important.
Now, it's not the most
beautiful logs viewer,
but when you have six
microservices times six
clusters, that's--
who can do the math
for me? (WHISPERS) 36.
The answer is 36.
36 different services running
around the world, right?
With Stackdriver Logging, I
was able to take all of those
into one centralized viewpoint.
I can go to any of
my clusters, any
of the containers
in my clusters,
and see the logs right there.
Something I didn't
think I would use,
but ended up using because I'm
really bad at writing code,
was tracing.
So this is a trace graph.
This is an actual trace
from one of my requests.
Who can see the really
weird, what in the world
is going on thing there?
I was actually not closing
a stream correctly.
I was never returning.
And so the process would just
start again after 30 seconds.
And so you can see
that really weird--
it's kind of blurry
on the screen,
but it goes for like 100
milliseconds, 100 milliseconds,
few hundred milliseconds,
through 30,000 milliseconds.
And then a few
hundred milliseconds.
So that was clearly
something broken.
And I could not figure it out.
But when I saw it
in this trace, it
was like really, really easy.
And because I write in
Node.js, except meme created,
which is in PHP,
interesting fact,
it's just Google Cloud
dot, like, start trace.
It's like one line of code to
get all this information, which
is really cool.
And then there's so much more.
Yeah, this is a small list
that me and a coworker
created over drinks one day.
And we're like, wow.
There's a lot of stuff to
talk about with microservices.
Everyone says they're easier
than monoliths, and something
something something, or
I don't know, whatever.
But you don't think
about a lot of things
when you're really doing them.
So people are taking pictures.
This is just a
random list, guys.
This is not real.
I'm kidding.
You can take your pictures.
Take your pictures of this.
So if you want to learn more
about microservices with us,
me and my coworker, Ray
Tsang, who's another Cloud DA,
we want to create a new blog
post slash video series.
This is me saying it now so
I'm forced to do it later.
Follow us on Medium and Twitter.
And hopefully, we'll announce
something later this year.
The two of us kind of sat
down and we're like, wow,
there's so many unknown
knowns, known unknowns,
unknown known
knowns, and who knows
what's going on in this
world of microservices.
A lot of people are
talking about it.
Let's get practical.
Let's just try to work
with the community
and understand
what we want to do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]